with the new year we often make the best
intentions for a new better healthier
version of ourselves but maybe our stuff
didn't quite get the memo and our spaces
and our belongings are as chaotic as our
2021.
so today i'm going to be sharing with
you the 15 items that i'm going to be
decluttering this month and some of them
i secretly want to hoard and keep and
i'm also going to be sharing with you
what i'm going to do with some of them
instead because sometimes i feel like we
talk about what to get rid of what to
clear out and how to make more space in
room but we don't talk about what you do
with these items that you're actually
decluttering so hopefully this list will
be helpful for you but no it is not
about decluttering items and just
getting rid of things it is more than
that it's about getting rid of excess
and waste and clutter to free up space
to give you peace of mind and make room
for the things that you do love enjoy
and use on a regular basis also before
we begin if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up to help support my
channel and if not by all means thumbs
it down but please give me some feedback
in the comments so that i know what to
work on okay first up
this bad boy a laptop so a couple of
months ago i was having some major
technical issues and i was taking hours
just to post videos um and to be able to
upload them because this computer i
basically will just describe the
situation as i was driving this tiny
little small car or maybe a bicycle and
i was trying to haul a big giant trailer
it just was not keeping up with the
amount of files and programs that i was
needing to use
and so it was time to let it go it was
either selling it or giving it away and
in my case i thought about it this way i
had an idea of who i could give it to i
have a niece i know that she needs one
or i could sell it and make a very
laughable amount of money and so i had
these two options and honestly even
though i knew what my heart said i
should do and i should give it away to
my niece i'll be honest in my brain i
thought what if i need it what if there
was a situation and i need a backup
computer and
i just had to kind of smack myself in
the face and say yes if i keep it i'm
maybe going to use it in the future in a
few years
in some sort of scenario likely never
but if i give it away
i know that it's going to be used it's
going to make a greater impact it's
going to be so helpful for her i so i
thought about all those options and and
so i am going to be giving it away
and along with that i had a mouse which
i realized i had not been using i
actually had this boxed up and i didn't
realize it until i decided that i was
going to give away the computer so it's
a perfectly usable mouse but for me i
actually even edit on photoshop with
just
you know my little
what do you call that thing the pad on
the computer i don't use the mouse and
so there's no need for that either so
this eliminates two items in one the
next item is one that i'm actually going
to be selling and it's my tony llama
cowgirl boots and i've actually had
these for
over five years now but i've worn them
about four or five times and i realized
that it was time to let these go because
i need some winter boots where i live it
actually gets below freezing and i
needed some boots but i could not
justify having a new pair of boots when
i have one pair of boots that i never
wear and so i decided i'm going to be
selling these i'll maybe get like five
or ten dollars for them but you know
what the money has already been spent
really the damage has been done i'm not
going to be getting that money back and
so for me i need to eliminate one and
just acknowledge that i already spent
the money it's done it's not coming back
and
just move on with the pair that i do
really like and enjoy and will wear so
in a way it's kind of eliminating the
guilt because when i see them i feel
guilty that i spent the money on them
and that i don't wear them the next item
is a handmade shawl and this one is
truly very very special to me and it's
kind of hard to get rid of so story with
this is my aunt and grandma in mexico
make handmade shawls and it takes them
hours to do they sell them in mexico for
dirt cheap i mean it is sad the amount
of money that they get paid for these
and so
what i did um and my mom did the last
time that she visited to mexico is we
bought several of them from them so that
they could kind of make some money and
we maybe could either keep them or sell
them my mom would sell them and i would
just hoard them because i didn't want to
get rid of them to me they were so
special they were made by hands
of people that i love and i just
couldn't let them go uh and then i
realized i have these beautiful items
that are
well made that some people love and
could use instead of keeping them boxed
up what would my grandma and my aunt
want would they want for these items to
be boxed up and locked away for nobody
to use or would they want people to
actually use them and love them and
enjoy them and so i thought of an
individual who is very classy she loves
handmade things and i decided to give
this to her so that she could make use
of it because really it was collecting
dust in my closet and i just did not
think that that was fair for an item
that i value and i think is very special
and beautiful sometimes i think that it
can be hard to get rid of an item if it
does bring that emotional value to me
those items do bring an emotional value
but i also think of it as
what would
this person want of that item would they
want this item to be boxed up or would
they want this item to be used and loved
and enjoyed okay next up is kind of a a
simple one it's sweatpants my husband
basically bought a new pair of
sweatpants and so we just didn't really
need an extra pair he had one that he
rarely ever wore and so this one is
going to be chunked away to donation
pile it's soft it's in good condition
but it was rarely used time to go the
next item is actually one that i'm kind
of embarrassed that i'm admitting to but
it's a table runner and placemats so to
give you the story this table that is
behind me was made by my husband he took
several days to make it because i really
wanted a farmhouse live edge table i
drew out the parameters of what i wanted
it to look like and he made it just the
way that i wanted it and then there i
went putting a table runner and
placemats on it to hide its beauty i
feel like basically i took this
beautiful piece of art and i slapped a
sticker on it to hide all of the beauty
that it provided which is kind of sad
and he never told me anything about it
but now i realize what what was i
thinking so i now decided i'm going to
be removing that we're just going to be
appreciating the natural beauty of
this art piece it's an art piece i want
to appreciate all of its imperfections
all of the grooves all of the little
holes and
little lines on them how smooth it is
and appreciate the meaning behind the
work that it took
and what it really means to us versus
just
an item that could be purchased from a
store to decorate something the next
item is rather a simple one and it's
napkin holders and i'm excited about
getting rid of it because it's one less
thing off this table so we can better
showcase its beauty but also we hadn't
gotten rid of these napkin holders
because we had had packs of disposable
napkins and i have over the years been
trying to purchase less and less
disposable items and purchase more
reusable however because we already had
these packs of disposable napkins i saw
it this way we have already purchased
them the damage has already been done to
the environment i can't just like put
them back in the tree they've already
been made and so i decided that we were
going to use them up until they were
finished and then we would go and buy
reusable napkins and so now we have
purchased some reusable napkins once
these disposable ones run out we will
use reusable from now on instead of
disposables and now we won't need the
napkin holders next up is this stack of
vcrs so i had some vcrs that we don't
have the ability to play because we
don't even have a vcr player however i
realized that there are places that can
transfer these videos into dvd format so
certain places like walmart cvs
walgreens can actually transfer this for
a cost however if you don't want to
actually pay for these items sometimes
you can look at purchasing these items
on dvd format so some of the old vcr
movies that we had had when we were kids
that i loved actually now have been made
in dvd format but for those special
movies like maybe you have home movies
that you just really don't want to get
rid of look into transferring them from
bcr into dvd next up is some kids
clothes so basically with kids they
outgrow their clothes so quickly and
what we do with the gently used clothes
is we take them to a consignment shop
that gives us a tiny amount of money for
it however i can use this amount of
money to purchase new items so i can
basically take the old items that no
longer fit them sell those for a small
amount of money but use that towards
purchasing new items that do fit them
that they can grow into and i'm also a
big fan of this because i feel like this
reduces waste this is one less item
that's produced new and i'm buying
something that is used so not only is it
better for the wallet but it's better
for the environment as well the next
item is some non-fitting shirts and this
one is something that i kind of had to
give myself permission on so here
recently i have now weaned my child from
breastfeeding and any woman who has ever
breastfed a child been pregnant or even
if you haven't hormones and things can
fluctuate and our weight can fluctuate
and you know what sometimes we need to
give ourselves permission
to have the items that make us feel good
and look good and not just have this
item to remind us that we need to get to
that weight or get to that way that we
were before i think that it's important
for us to realize that we should accept
ourselves who we are now and have the
clothes that make us feel good so for me
i'm eliminating these they no longer fit
me
the bosoms are not what they used to be
that's okay the next item is kind of a
sentimental item for me it's harder for
me than it is for my daughter and this
is stuffed kids toys our daughter has
autism and she plays with toys
differently where another child may play
house and play dress up and those sorts
of things she likes to line things up
and that is perfectly okay
you know i didn't realize
with her that this was autism that we
were seeing and i tried to really force
on her well let's play this and let's
play that and and i've now come to
realize that it's okay
so with me getting rid of some of these
toys that she has never played with it's
not getting rid of this ideal of what i
had of parenting and childhood would be
for her
rather it's me telling grown up anna i
love you just the way you are you don't
have to be anyone else but you and if
you don't want to play this way then
that's okay i accept you just as you are
and so you can see that getting rid of
an item can be so much more than just
getting rid of a physical item
it's really what ties what emotional
ties the item has is it providing guilt
does it make you feel like you need to
be a certain way be a certain person and
so i just kind of encourage you to look
at your items there may be certain items
that are really sentimental and
difficult for you to get rid of and just
kind of evaluate the why is it because
it reminds you of a past relationship
and you don't want to let it go
or is it something that really provides
you joy or is it because it was an item
that belonged to your deceased
grandmother and it's really difficult
for you to let that go just really
evaluate the emotions behind it because
a lot of the items that we have have a
lot of emotional ties and it can be very
difficult to get rid of these items i
feel like i've included a lot of
sentimental items and then i just throw
in some random ones like this basket so
we have had uh this basket for a while
and i've i've had it in the closet as a
maybe donating item but i've kept it
just in case because you know just in
case may happen and i think that with
storage items that can really happen a
lot so we have these storage items and
we want to just fill them up and so i
realized that if i'm not using storage
items all the better because if i have
storage items that aren't being used i'm
going to find some items to put inside
them so that just kind of makes more
clutter so you know what
goodbye storage basket next up is some
non-used puzzles so if you have any
puzzles that are maybe like missing
pieces or just puzzles that are not
really used in general analyze what
kinds of puzzles you actually use what
kinds of games you are enjoying and what
items have a little too much dust that
maybe haven't been pulled out in a while
because perhaps it's time to let them go
next up is a wine bottle opener okay
this one's not really that big of a deal
it's a tiny little item but we realized
that we don't really drink wine we have
had a wine bottle that was gifted to us
months ago and we still have yet to open
it and it's actually not even one that
has the cork it's just the screw on and
so if we're not really purchasing wine
we're not really drinking wine on a
regular basis like maybe once a year why
do we even have a wine bottle opener and
lastly an umbrella so i had asked you
guys in a previous video if you
recommended that i keep or declutter an
umbrella because we don't use an
umbrella we go outside and if it rains
we just get rained on and we embrace
that and we just have learned to just
enjoy that and be okay with that so
we're actually going to be parting ways
with the umbrella i don't think that we
need to have one more item if it's not
being used and it could certainly be
used by somebody else so sometimes i
think just look at your items and see if
you're not using them maybe think of
somebody that can use them sometimes
that helps me when i'm not sure if i
should get rid of an item if i have
someone in mind that i know can use it
and love it then that really eases my
guilt and makes it a lot easier to get
rid of so hopefully this list has been
enjoyable it's been helpful but if so
please give it a thumbs up i would love
to hear your comments as well though
what items are you thinking of
decluttering what ways are you going to
be clearing your space in your home and
making room for the things that you love
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to hear from you until next
time bye
[Music]